failure seemed properly is just a
recognition of fast learning so I have
training wheels which I try to put on
this concept within X to try to help
everyone get comfortable with the idea
here's an example you're working on a
project it either has an Achilles heel
or it doesn't would we like to discover
that Achilles heel if it exists now or
later if you say later you've just
signed up to be intellectually dishonest
you're not really gonna sign up for that
as soon as you acknowledge that should
it have an Achilles heel we'd like to
know about that now rather than later
then it becomes the right way for us to
behave to check to see if it has an
Achilles heel now right now if it has
the Achilles heel we'll end the project
and we'll go find something better to do
and if it doesn't have an Achilles heel
we can move forward with that increased
level of excitement and certainty that
we're on the right track let's pretend
that you are setting out to make a time
machine at X and you have two choices
one to cause a pebble or a mouse to move
backwards one minute in time to actually
cause some small amount of time travel
or to design the user interface for the
cockpit of the time machine I think we
could all agree in this particular
example that working on the user
interface for the cockpit once you get
it done it will look like you've made
progress but you haven't you've made
motion we can all sit there look at your
cockpit and say the chances that we
succeed are exactly the same as they
were before we've not actually made any
progress because all of the risk was on
the part you chose not to do what you
should have done first was the other one
so the way that our shorthand for this
at X is that we we joke hashtag monkey
first similar to the time
if you're trying to get a monkey to
stand on a pedestal 10 feet high and
recite Shakespeare monologues and you
have a choice between training the
monkey first and building the pedestal
if you build the pedestal first when
your boss walks by he's like hey nice
pedestal and then you feel good you just
did something useful you just got a
little bit of you know attaboy that's
why people do that but you've uh terally
wasted your company's money if you build
the pedestal first because all of the
hard part is getting the monkey to
recite Shakespeare if you can get the
monkey to recite Shakespeare we can
always build the pedestal afterwards but
if you can't thank goodness we didn't
spend a moment or a penny building what
turned out it to be a useless pedestal
now in order to get a culture a tax to
do that we need to reward people when
they do it so when someone raises their
hand and says my project looks really
good but I've discovered I don't think
it's gonna work out because of this
subtle but important issue and those 10
people now need to find new jobs if we
say now sucks to be you know one at X
will ever again raise their hand and say
that but if we say to them hey that was
awesome
what incredible intellectual honesty you
just displayed and good critical
thinking to have discovered this we're
gonna work super hard to find all of you
new jobs somewhere at X or at alphabet
we're gonna give you all bonuses for
having ended your project so
thoughtfully take long vacations and
then when you're done come back and join
another project here and get going again
with extra levels of passion because
you're now working on something that you
don't secretly know is going to fail at
some point in the future which is how
you would have felt if you had stuck on
your old project people are sad when
they have to end their projects they
don't end their projects lightly but
because they've come to understand that
ending their project is just
being intellectually honest it's driving
for high efficiency which is why we use
the word factory and tie it to moonshots
because we're trying to systematize
innovation we're trying to drive to high
efficiency innovation and that can best
be done by being honest when you're on
the wrong track and that is failing fast
[Music]